WHO REFUSE TO DO WHAT IS
NECESSARY TO SECURE THE
HOMELAND.
AND THAT'S THE ANGLE.
JOINING US NOW WITH REACTION
THE AMERICAN IMMIGRATION
LAWYERS ASSOCIATION.
ANATASIA I'M SURE YOU DISAGREE
WITH WITH A LOT OF WHAT I SAY.
I'LL JUST LET YOU COMMENT.
>> AS I EXPLAINED EARLIER A
LOT OF THE COMMENTS ARE ON THE
POLITICAL CLIMATE ON ECONOMICS,
I'LL LIMIT MY COMMENTS TO THE
IMMIGRATION LAWS, AND HAPPY TO
DISCUSS THE POLICIES AND HOW
THOSE ARE --.
>> SO YOU'RE TELLING US WHAT
YOU WON'T TALK ABOUT SO LET'S
TALK ABOUT WHAT, WHY THERE'S
BEEN, AND I THINK WE HAVE A
GRAPHIC, A 10-FOLD INCREASE IN
THE CLAIMS FOR ASYLUM COMING
OUT OF THESE NORTHERN TRIANGLE
COUNTRIES, ESPECIALLY
HONDURAS.
REQUESTS INCREASED 10-FOLD
BETWEEN 2009 AND 2016.
WHY DO YOU THINK IT IS?
>> AGAIN, I MEAN THERE ARE
ISSUES IN THOSE COUNTRIES,
THERE'S A LOT OF POLITICAL
UNREST.
THERE HAVE BEEN JUST
TRADITIONALLY, THERE WERE AS A
RESULT OF DEPORTATIONS A LOT
OF THE PRISONERS THAT WERE IN
GANGS IN L.A. AND WERE
DEPOURED HAVE TAKEN ADVANTAGE
OF POLITICAL CHAOS IN THE
COUNTRIES AND WERE ABLE TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF SYSTEMS,
WHICH LEADS TO VIOLENCE.
WE SEE A LOT OF THE ASYLUM
SEEKERS ARE WOMEN, AND
CHILDREN --.
>> A LOT OF THEM AREN'T.
A LOT ARE WOMEN AND CHILDREN
AND VERY SYMPATHETIC AND WE
WANT NOTHING BUT GOOD THINGS
TO HAPPEN TO ALL PEOPLE WHO
WANT A BETTER LIFE FOR THEIR
FAMILIES BUT THE QUESTION IS,
UNDER OUR CURRENT LAW, AND
YOU'RE AN EXPERT AS AN
IMMIGRATION CASE WHEN I WAS A
DEFENSE ATTORNEY BELIEVE IT OR
NOT BUT THOSE LAWS REQUIRE AN
INCREDIBLE FEAR OF PERSECUTION
YET IN THE SURVEYS DONE, OF
THESE MIGRANTS, IN TRANSIT OR
WHEN THEY'RE BEING DEPORTED
BACK HOME, THEY OVERWHELMINGLY
STATE THEIR CONCERN IS AN
ECONOMIC ONE, AND YOU CAN'T
BLAME THEM.
IT'S HARD TO MAKE A LIFE IN
GUATAMALA OR EL SALVADOR.
I SPENT A LOT OF TIME IN BOTH
COUNTRIES.
THEY'RE BEAUTIFUL COUNTRIES
WITH ROTTEN GOVERNMENTS BUT
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A SITUATION
WHERE WE HAVE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF CASES BACKLOGGED
IN THE IMMIGRATION COURTS AND
FRANKLY WE'RE OUT OF PERSONNEL
AND MONEY AS FAR AS PROCESSING
THIS SO HOW WOULD YOU BALANCE
THOSE CONCERNS OF THE UNITED
STATES, WITH OUR OWN HOMELESS
PROBLEM, OUR OWN VETERANS ON
THE STREET PROBLEMS, OPOID
CRISIS, OVER CROWDED SCHOOLS,
WITH THE DESIRES OF FOREIGNERS
WHO COME HERE FOR A BETTER
LIFE.
>> I MEAN I THINK EARLIER YOU
WERE TALKING ABOUT THE
CORRUPTION IN HONDURAS AND THE
DEMANDS PUT ON THESE OFFICIALS,
AND I THINK THAT WHAT IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT IN ALL OF
THIS, IS THE RULE OF LAW, IS
DUE PROCESS.
WHERE AMERICA, THE
CONSTITUTION IS VERY STRONG.
WE HAVE VERY CLEAR GUIDANCE
AND RULES ON WHAT WE ARE
EXPECTED, WHAT WE EXPECT TO
GIVE AS FAR AS LEGAL PROCESS
AND PROCEDURE, SO THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT I DON'T THINK
WE SHOULD COMPROMISE ON, AND I
DON'T THINK WE SHOULD PICK AND
CHOOSE WHO GETS DUE PROCESS.
THE FUNDAMENTAL PART OF OUR
CONSTITUTION.
>> RIGHT, WELL IT'S A
FUNDAMENTAL CONCERN FOR
AMERICANS THAT WE HAVE BORDERS
THAT ARE ACTUALLY ENFORCED,
AND LAWS THAT ARE NOT GAMD BY
ATTORNEYS WHO GO DOWN TO
MEXICO OR CENTRAL AMERICA AND
LITERALLY COACH PEOPLE AS TO
HOW TO MAKE THEIR CASE AND
MAKE THEIR CLAIM.
IT GOES FROM REPUTATION TO
ADVOCACY FOR POLICY CHANGE OR
ENTRANCE INTO THE UNITED
STATES DESPITE THE FACT A LOT
OF THE LAWYERS DON'T KNOW MUCH
IF ANYTHING ABOUT THE
BACKGROUND OF THE MIGRANTS.
I WANT TO PLAY A SOUNDBITE
FROM THE HOMELAND SECURITY
SECRETARY ABOUT WHO ELSE IS
TRYING TO GAIN ACCESS TO
AMERICA.
LET'S WATCH.
>> BORDER SECURITY IS NATIONAL
SECURITY.
WHAT WE SEE THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY, WE SEE 15
TERRORISTS EITHER PLANNING
TRAVEL OR ACTUALLY TRAVELING
TO THE UNITED STATES EACH DAY,
KNOWN AS SUSPECTED TERRORISTS.
THAT MEANS THEY'RE COMING
THROUGH OUR LEGAL LAND PORTS
AND AIR.
>> ARE YOU CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT?
THAT IN THESE CARAVANS, I MEAN
AGAIN IT'S A DROP IN THE
BUCKET COMPARED TO THE
THOUSANDS UPON THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN PROCESSED
INTO OUR COUNTRY SINCE LAST
OCTOBER, BUT IT'S THE VISUAL
IMAGE I THINK THAT GETS A LOT